my name is Dalton and I'm here to talk
to you guys about building singer
engineers so thank you for coming again
hello
we've had some really great talks so far
how's everyone enjoying the conference
yeah I sure do feel and this is my first
time at Strange Loop I'm honored to be
able to come here and have these great
conversations and talk with everybody
and I've also noticed a trend a lot of
people from different domains talking
about how we really think about doing
better in in whatever it is that we
enjoy doing writing software building
architecture things like that so I think
that's that's been really great and that
sort of aligns with what I want to talk
to you today about just to get some of
the formalities out I work as a software
engineer at a company called Riskalyze
so we're a thin tech startup out of
Auburn California if you haven't heard
of that it's it's about two hours north
of San Francisco in a small town up
there and we make a product for
financial advisors to analyze the risk
in their clients portfolio and our real
main goal is to empower fearless
investing for as many people as possible
and and really what I want to talk about
is it's kind of my experience at
Riskalyze and and what that's kind of
taught me about the community and maybe
some lessons that we can learn so
getting back to things building senior
engineers that's that's an interesting
title but what are we actually what are
we actually talking about there so let's
just sort of unpack that title a little
a little bit so just to kind of bring
some clarity here engineer can mean very
different things in the context of this
talk I'm going to be talking about
software engineers that is my background
and and so I'm not going about anyone
whose job is to design architect or Bill
software maybe you're called a developer
maybe you're called an engineer maybe
just a coder maybe even the designer
that really specializes in in software
and application development and works
very closely with people that write code
and so what do we mean by senior what
I'm really talking about is those of us
that may be more advanced in our careers
we're not fresh out of boot camp or out
of any sort of schooling and not only
maybe we do have some advanced technical
skills but also we we've sort of evolved
beyond just that technical level and
maybe we've also got some skills around
leadership around effective
communication and kind of helping
projects move along that sort of thing
and so this could include
if you are a team lead for an
engineering game here is a staff
engineer if you're an engineering
manager that's heavily involved with
code that gets written and moving that
software process forward I'm referring
to you
so why building well so again a lot of
the content of this talk comes from my
background and my observations over the
past few years and I've noticed that as
a tech industry we can do some amazing
things we build software that connects
people that helps them to consume and
share knowledge we can solve common pain
points for people maybe things that are
very repetitive or boring we can
leverage software to kind of do that and
they can go on and do things that make
them more happy in their life or we also
build things that are just fun sometimes
so games and things that just kind of
bring joy to people's lives and enrich
their lives but I've also seen that as
an industry and as a community we could
do a better job of providing guidance
and opportunities for career progression
depending on what your background was it
seems like everybody gets
to appointing their career where they're
left with certain gaps and it's kind of
up to them to fill in those gaps or
maybe to find a community they can give
them that guidance and I feel like that
shouldn't that shouldn't be something
that we leave up to each individual so
often so I'll talk a little bit about my
journey into software development so my
current title at Riskalyze is a senior
software engineer but if we go back two
years ago I would have never imagined
that that would be what you would call
me if we go back maybe five years ago I
didn't actually know how to write a for
loop but but I had been writing
JavaScript my background sort of came
from a web design the only degree I
actually have is in computer technology
which basically means I can I can be an
entry-level helpdesk support person I
can help you fix your computer I can fix
your copy machine that kind of thing but
I was really interested in in building
things on the web and the way that there
was that power to connect you I didn't
have the resources to go to school so in
my spare time and my evenings I would
just kind of go online and find ways to
learn this stuff if we go back to around
2011 or 2012 I decided you know what I
feel like I really enjoy this work I'm
just gonna dive into it headfirst and so
I decided to freelance and I didn't make
much money but I did learn that I really
like application development but that
required at the time what I called real
programming so I went back and I learned
like I had been writing JavaScript and
PHP for a while or cutting and pasting
that code I went back and I learned like
what are the fundamentals of programming
in JavaScript what are the fundamentals
of programming in PHP what are those
fundamentals in Python and so I spent a
few months learning Python got sort of
involved in Ruby for a little bit and
and then back to JavaScript exploring
different frameworks and things like
that also had a job for about four years
where I was the entire technical staff
on site and so that gave me a lot of
freedom to explore different ideas and
just kind of figure things out
and and kind of figure out how to make
things work but all along this time I
didn't really have any kind of
structured guidance I didn't know about
communities of other people doing these
things I kind of knew that they were
around but I was living in a small town
in Northern California outside of San
Francisco and I didn't see a whole lot
of that around me so so how did I kind
of progress I interviewed a lot so for a
over a two-year period I would was
living in the Sacramento region I grew
up in Oakland so I knew kind of what was
going on in the in the Bay Area and the
East Bay and I had family down there so
I would drive down for an interview or
kind of batch them up several interviews
every three or four months I did it in
four-month junks because it was very
stressful and very draining on me and
that was all I could handle but I'd go
and and I bombed some interviews and
then I kind of not get great feedback
but I kind of take it upon myself to
analyze maybe what I did wrong and see
what things I could work on and then in
a few more months I'd go out and
interview again a lot of my feedback
looks like this so we're looking for a
more senior candidate you're very nice
you seem pleasant to work with we're
really just looking for more senior
candidate I really didn't know what that
meant and I feel like we still often
times will give feedback like that and
and this kind of leaves it up to the
candidate to to figure out their path i
I think that's not a great experience
and I think that we can do better as a
community eventually I found channels to
get useful feedback some of that was
through interviews or
teams were actually kind enough to give
me some very direct and open feedback
and then I could see where my path
forward was some of that was discovering
things like local meetups and through
speaking at local JavaScript meetups and
things I would connect with folks and
ask them questions and then I get feet
up feedback that way eventually I
started learning whether the resources
on career progression certain blog posts
and things like that work and I would
find those resources but I really had to
kind of gather all that together on my
own I think we as a community and
especially those of us that are at a
certain level in our career we could do
more to help the people that are next in
line give them some guidance and kind of
illuminate that path forward but why why
why would you want to do this as a
certainly not your responsibility I
would say from my own observation that
it benefits you and your team it also
benefits the community and and all of us
if we work in open-source software we
depend on that community pretty heavily
and it's also not as hard as you might
think if we just really kind of think
about the problem but it is a big
problem and so where do we start
this talk is not long enough to kind of
cover the whole issue so really I'm just
trying to get the conversation started
and so I'm going to pick one area where
I feel that we could have a lot of
impact it certainly did in my case
obviously that area is interviews so I
think interviews are a great place to
start because from a company perspective
is obvious benefits obviously we have
lots of jobs to fill
and if we can't staff our teams
correctly then that means we can't move
as quickly and we can't execute execute
on those ideas that help our business to
grow also these are good jobs they're
they tend to be fairly lucrative and
they're it's not like manual labor where
it kind of drags down on your body your
and things like that so we're also
helping people kind of have a better
quality of life but it's also an
interview is kind of like a it's kind of
like an exam that you go through maybe
even a gauntlet but the benefit of it is
that it really showcases where your
strengths and your weaknesses are and it
would be great to surface those in that
place where we can really see them
highlighted and give some really good
feedback but I definitely don't want to
say that interviews are broken and and
they're just terrible
so what is working well currently when
we think about the the common things in
technical software engineering
interviews I see some positives we have
high standards and that's great because
if we are keeping a high standard of
code quality within our current current
code base we want new people to be on
board and have that same level of
quality as they add to our code base we
also kind of focus on team impact so
when we're interviewing people we're not
just thinking am i as the hiring manager
do I think this person is competent and
will work well with me it's more about
thinking about my entire team and how is
this person going to fit in with that
entire dynamic well how are their
strengths and weaknesses going to going
to complement other people on my team
and that's a common thing that I think
we we definitely want to keep we also
barrel value experience overhead
knowledge so what does that actually
mean
so by saying that what I mean is if
you've got a CS degree that's great but
that's usually not the content of the
interview it's usually can you write
some code
can you diagram the theory of how a
particular program or function will work
we really want to see if you can like
actually do stuff versus just having a
great-looking resume and in all
industries that's that's not the case so
what are some areas where we can improve
I think we as companies and teams could
be really clear about what we value on
our team I think we could work hard to
identify the traits that are actually
going to matter to our organization and
then we could take just a little bit of
effort to give some useful feedback for
that candidate whether or not they make
it through that's going to be very
valuable for them and just a couple
sentences of really honest and direct
feedback was very impactful in my career
and I think it would be for others so as
teams what do you value Johnny ray
Austin gave an awesome talk yesterday
called a theory of everything and one of
the sort of key aspects that I took out
of that is this concept of teams coming
up with a set of core values for their
engineering organization what's really
valuable on my team and so the benefit
of that is when I interview candidates
now I can interview in terms of values
which transcend culture and personal
backgrounds and things like that they're
really about the way this person works
and how they're going to be effective on
my team and so I can see not do I like
hanging out with this person I can see
do they align with the values on my team
and if there's alignment and there is a
certain level of technical qualification
then they're probably a good match so
[Music]
obviously values differ by team so this
is kind of one of those it depends
moments I'm not going to prescribe
anything because everybody has different
business use cases everybody has
different environments they work with
but if you're not really sure I'm going
to give some examples of things that
I've seen that are they tend to be
valuable across engineering
organizations so if you're looking for
those diamonds in the rough
maybe people that don't come from a
traditional background maybe people that
would be great on your team and you
might otherwise pass them by if all you
focus on is how how well they do on a
white board interview here's some things
I think are valuable to kind of look for
a communication curiosity passion and
determination and there's many more good
attributes those are just kind of I had
to pick some in this talk couldn't be
three hours long so that's kind of what
I picked but what you'll see is these
don't really focus on that technical
competency yes that needs to be there
but I think if you're really focused on
hiring by values you'll know when the
technical competency is there and you'll
know when the technical competency is is
close and maybe their values align so
closely with your teams that maybe it's
worth a little bit of investment to hire
them and help quickly get them up to
speed on the technical side so let's
take communication what does that matter
people that are good communicators tend
to be good at receiving an understanding
feedback they'll also ask for help they
have empathy and and because of that
they also tend to help others and also
be effective at helping others
but what would this actually look like
in an interview and and I should also
say that for most of these slides I'm
I'm sort of talking to that person that
would be a mentor a hiring manager
someone more senior but if you happen to
be in that junior level look out for
these actually beats these are things
you should be trying to emulate if you
want to get that next great job so what
this actually look like an interview
well we'd be looking for people that can
very easily explain concepts in in just
kind of common language because that
that usually gives a sense that you
you've kind of done some programming and
you really you really get how things
work people that also don't just recite
their job history but they can kind of
tell you like a story like what is the
actual career progression and how does
that fit in with your life and not just
I worked here than I worked here than I
worked here people that tend to be
conversational so they're calm they
maybe they ask the interviewer how their
day was what's your family like that
kind of thing that tends to be a sign
that someone's just they're just
naturally very good at communication and
someone that also is able to use the
feedback that an interviewer will give
to effectively sort of get themselves
unstuck because these technical
interviews they can be pretty intense
and you will get stuck that's just what
happens someone that's good at taking
and giving feedback that's good at that
communication though will be able to use
that and effectively get themselves
unstuck securio see curiosity excuse me
the curious person is one that I think
of that they kind of take the initiative
to find out how things work they were
they the kid that was maybe opening up
VCRs to like figure out what what went
on in there and they're also the person
that
wants to understand what the runtime of
the language is doing because of that
they tend to be great debuggers because
they don't just see an error and think
okay that's the fix they wonder why did
that ever happen could it have been
triggered by something else in the
system and they tend to think at a very
high systems level and understand the
connections that things have within a
software system and also challenges that
existing assumptions so oftentimes when
we've been working on a team for a while
and and that team has been pretty
cohesive there are things that we may be
doing things in our code base that are
they're working but maybe they could be
better and a curious person can come
into your organization maybe they'll ask
the question like why why is this done
this way and if if that answer is just
because it is you kind of want that
person to kind of push a little more
and say Oh have you considered this
could it be done this way it's not to
say that that your existing way is wrong
but there is value in having that person
that's going to ask why is this this way
so what's this look like in an interview
again this is the type of person who
asked the why questions maybe they're
given a problem given a list of integers
that's unordered sort them something
something like that I probably should
have thought of an example ahead of time
but anyway they would probably ask well
why are we sorting this or did this data
come from who's going to use the data
after it's sorted
just things like that like they want to
dig a little deeper until they can fully
understand the problem and that that
type of thinking is is very valuable to
have on your team so also if they don't
know something they know where to look
it up so this is the type of person
that maybe when they get an error
message they don't just go to stack
overflow
I work with JavaScript a lot so maybe
they go to Indian to like actually find
out why a function works this way
why concat returns a copy of an array
and push just manipulates the existing
array they they actually want to know
that and they know where to look that up
if they don't already know the answer so
they probably also tried a few
programming languages not not in a
practical sense maybe they don't work
with these day-to-day but they're just
interested in like how do things work
over here if they've written JavaScript
maybe they've tried out how maybe they
print out reason maybe they've tried out
back in languages like rust but they
they've they've kind of tried some
things and they that's enabled them to
kind of think about problems in a
different way versus someone that's only
worked with like their most loved
language and as a bonus when they get
stuck on something in the interview this
curious person that's not going to be
good enough for them to just kind of go
home they're actually going to research
like why why didn't that work for me and
they'll probably follow up with the
interviewer to say hey that that error
that I made I was able to research it
and this is what I did wrong this is
what I actually should have done and and
I learned some stuff so yeah if you ever
get one of those follow-up emails that's
probably a person to maybe give a second
look passion so the the passionate
person is someone that X pride in their
work they're always trying to improve
they're also going to be very motivating
because they're very energetic about
their work and they'll take the
initiative to learn new things and also
kind of share that with their team what
do they look like in an interview
they're probably a person that has side
projects and things that they've built
just for fun they are the type of person
who
they're attending meetups and also
participating in those meetups so maybe
they've given even just a lightning talk
maybe they've written blog posts a
YouTube channel in any of these things
depending on your situation if if you're
this person don't think that you have to
be giving talks while that is great I
don't think that you have to be building
toy projects people have families and
they have lives and and circumstances
differ but there should be some sign
that you are doing things outside of
work just because you love writing
software so much that you can't contain
it and that should come out in some way
that the interviewer can see and so if
that's not a parent like highlight that
and if you were in the interviewer try
to try to push just kind of ask I see
this stuff on your resume what what else
do you do
that's code related be beside your
day-to-day job and I've also kind of
noticed this trend that they tend to be
passionate about something else outside
of their technical domain so maybe they
run maybe they lift weights maybe
they're big into music maybe they like
they like baking I've seen lots of
different passions some can just be
really into reading and literature and
things like that
but they tend to be passionate about
something that kind of helps them step
away from their work but also keeps
their brain active in some manner
usually you can ask them to give you
like one favorite book technical and
non-technical and they will very quickly
kind of have an answer for you there so
the determination why why is this
important we want people on our teams
who aren't going to give up so this
person will have sort of shown that
throughout their life they they have not
given up on things because of that
they're not they don't have a tendency
to complain but they'll actually propose
Lucian's is the type of person that says
hey this isn't working for me I think
this could fix it but I'm not able to do
that for some reason or I've already
tried this this and this what am I
missing because if you can give me that
missing piece I can go back and fix it
myself so they're very motivated to to
help rather than just complain that
things aren't going their way they also
tend to show empathy for others because
they maybe had some struggles they
understand that people struggle and that
tends to make them a little bit more
empathetic so what does this look like
an interview usually they can talk about
some things that that maybe didn't go
quite right in their life this can be
technical this can be non-technical or
whatever just they understand that
things are not always rosy and and
sometimes things go wrong in the world
they can also speak about the positive
impacts that they've had in someone
else's life maybe this is helping
someone else learn the code maybe this
is helping a family member out of a
financial struggle really doesn't matter
just you can see that they value having
a positive impact in other lives and
they have some concrete examples to show
when they've helped with that they also
tend to stay calm and positive when an
interviewer isn't going their way this
is very difficult for me and it still is
when I get stressed like I just I get
bummed and but I have definitely seen
that the more I work on this it it makes
a really positive impact and from a
working perspective if you're building
non-trivial software things are not
going to go your way most of the time
there there will be struggles so you
want the person that is comfortable
being uncomfortable and can still remain
positive and can still kind of lift
everyone else up and this person can
also talk about some tough choices
they've made to kind of get something
done especially in terms of software I
was chatting with some folks last night
about kind of signs that they use to to
see what level a person is at in their
software development career when they
are interviewing and one of the
questions they like to ask is like what
do you hate most about software and if
someone can like give you aids story
about that they've probably been through
some struggles they probably written a
lot of software to get to that point
because if you're just kind of following
along with tutorials for this or that
framework you don't really get to the
point where there's a thing that you
hate that kind of takes some experience
to get to that point so those are just
some examples maybe all of those don't
align with your team's goals but say
that you have identified what your
team's values are and you're
interviewing a person what if they are a
good fit or excuse me
what if they're just not a good fit this
could be because maybe their technical
skills just aren't there yet and they
kind of align with a lot of those values
but the technical skills just aren't
there we still do need to write software
at the end of the day and if if they
were like me and couldn't write a for
loop that's a problem so what do we do
in that situation well I think we should
give some honest and actionable feedback
and here are some examples or here's an
example so it it be okay and there's a
lot of feedback like this that people
will give that your technical skills
weren't a solid is we would have liked
realize that fonts kind of thin so I'm
not sure if you guys can see that but
your technical skills weren't as solid
as we would have liked so that's okay I
know it had to do with my technical
skills but I don't really know what I
need to work on from that feedback so
here's another example you've got a good
grasp of the fundamentals but she seemed
to struggle at finding the most optimal
solution to the problem
I'd suggest you brush up on your
algorithms so it's a slight change but I
know exactly what I need to go learn if
I know nothing about rhythms I know I
need to like start with what's an
algorithm and how do you get good at
that if I know that they gave me a very
specific algorithm that I hadn't seen
before I know I need to brush up on
those types of algorithms and data
structures that are good at solving
those so I can use this and actually go
and level up and I also want to say that
I I know that there are there are
reasons that companies don't get
feedback some of them are for legal
reasons some of them are just for PR
sometimes you don't feel comfortable
from an organizational level giving good
detailed feedback but I'd suggest really
thinking about if there's good reasons
for those and if there isn't some kind
of way that we can provide useful
feedback for the candidate so what if
they are a great fit awesome
you're done not really so now the real
building begins you can build up a
candidate who maybe didn't work out by
kind of giving them a nugget of
knowledge that they can take and
progress with that but if somebody is a
good fit and we actually want to onboard
them on our team
then we've then we've got a little bit
more work to do so I'd suggest having a
detailed plan for success
think about what they need to do on
their first day to be successful
think about how soon they can get into
actually writing code and committing
code into your codebase and it'd be
great if you could think about a first
project that they can just dive into
right away and also the so any any
support or assistance that they'll need
to be successful throughout that process
it'd also be great to designate one
person they can go with or go to with
any questions concerns they have maybe
they're just kind of overwhelmed because
if we're trying to have them dive in to
the codebase as soon as possible that
can be overwhelming so it'd be great to
designate one person and say hey if you
have any concerns go to this person
they're here for you
give them a project as soon as possible
so they get an immediate sense of how
your team works what the pace of your
work is things like your code style and
and all of those things that are very
crucial to working effectively as teams
help them dive into that as soon as
possible and that is going to stress
them out
I would through this process but it was
very helpful to have people check in
with me regularly and remind me of where
I could go to for support in those
situations and and so some examples of
that were if your team does lots of
player programming and that's very
important like pair with them as often
as possible for that first two to three
months if if code quality and sort of
cross team communication is very
important do lots of code reviews the
company I work for communication is very
important across the entire company not
just engineering and so my first three
months I was doing code reviews either
having my code review with someone to
understand the style of the code and
what the what the standards were or also
reviewing other people's code which was
a really good way to get a sense for
what I should be shooting for so that is
a lot of work and I mentioned benefits
what are the benefits so from a company
and you and your team's perspective I
you're going to get very perspectives in
your organization and this does tend to
raise the level and quality of your code
because you kind of have more checks to
make sure that you're doing the right
thing you're going to build sort of a
growth mindset across your team because
if you're working hard to onboard new
folks and help
kind of level up quickly other people
within the organization already you're
going to take advantage of that and
pretty soon your entire team is gonna be
thinking about growth and you'll be
doing better work and also I've seen
this with companies that I've gotten
very good feedback from that candidates
were for other people and you will have
a ton of candidates which increases the
amount of really good candidates and
those jobs will stay open for shorter
times so what are the benefits of the
community well I think we get we kind of
raise the level of the engineering
skills across our community again most
of us work with open source technologies
in some way and so as we build up the
community we all kind of benefit from
that well start to define better
resources for these new people so it'll
be very clear where new people can go to
get the resources for whatever level
they happen to be in their career and
then we'll be able to build more whole
things which is that's kind of my goal
so what else can you do well
volunteering at meetups is a really good
place to start maybe your team can host
a meet-up maybe you can send some of
your more qualified engineers to kind of
speak at meetups about things that are
very important to your organization
that'll be a signal to new people
attending those meet ups and hey you're
a company if that aligns with my values
your company I want to work for I think
I want to apply there
apprenticeships are also a very good
thing I know there are some companies
doing this if if more people could do it
I think it's something that we all
should kind of consider and consider
what does that look like for our budget
and what kind of resources can we
allocate for that mentor at events like
railsbridge
free code camp was really helpful to me
Russ bridge was just mentioned there's
tons of organizations like this that
kind of
to people who wouldn't traditionally be
found in our community mentored some of
those what you're doing is letting
people know that you're out there and
then you care about them and kind of
align with their values once they get to
the point where their technical skills
are useful to you they're probably going
to apply at your company or refer other
other people who are qualified to apply
your company and then publish and speak
about your values one thing that I that
really kind of stood out to me when I
looked into Riskalyze was that not only
on the website do we have the entire
company's core values listed out but
every single person that I talked to
from my initial phone screen through all
of my interviews everyone actually
seemed to stand by those core values and
I could kind of remember them and
remember people's interactions and think
oh this is that one okay they actually
do kind of stand by these core values so
published and speak about those values
and let other people know if they have
that same sort of value alignment that
you're there and you're probably a good
place to work for so I don't want to
make this talk spiritual or anything
like that but I actually found a really
nice quote from the Bible and I thought
it really kind of summed up what I
wanted to say so it it says he received
free gift free and for context this was
kind of Jesus sending his apostles he
had just given them powers to to do
miracles and cure people and and and all
that great stuff but what he was saying
was going on in the community and take
these gifts that I'd given you and kind
of spread them around but don't charge
anyone because I gave them to you for
free so give them to others for free I
think this really kind of applies and
can be useful for us to think about as
an open source community that most of us
depend on open source and that's been
very valuable for our careers but that
means that most of our careers are based
on us getting things for free so I think
it'd be great if we could spin just a
little bit of time and effort
to give something free to that next
person in line who maybe isn't sure what
they should do next and that's really
just my encourage meant to everybody
we received free gift free so thank you
I think we're about out of the time for
questions but she can find me on Twitter
and github at Dalton a Mitchell and
that's my email I'll be here for the
rest of the conference so I'm happy to
chat and answer more questions about
this Thanks
[Applause]